nir la gérald le coût net budgétaire 730
millions de dollars et la taxe d'accise
sur le tabac
l'ajout de l'augmentation 685 millions
donc ça résume à peu près le
choisiraient de budget et des économies
supplémentaires de 2 milliards 100
millions mais quand on regarde vraiment
toutes les mesures et qu'on prend
l'argent 900 en faisant complètement
abstraction des de l'argent qu'on va
chercher dans ce qui est dit et ce qui
était déjà dans les budgets auparavant
c'est vraiment 730 millions et vous
l'avez dit c'est si mince et un
programme minceur avec des économies
additionnelles
on met la table on installe et je vous
dirais la plus belle vaisselle pour le
budget de l'an prochain
c'est l'an prochain avec un surplus qui
est déjà rendu à 7 milliards
et ça je pense que ça va être un minimum
dans les surplus l'an prochain parce
qu'on va vouloir annoncer le
prolongement du celi la l'élargissement
du celi le compte d'épargné libre
d'impôt on va vouloir faire des annonces
sur le fractionnement de revenus on va
nous annoncer le surplus sans d'autres
surprises égalé on va les faire si vous
le voulez bien leur prochain
toutes les annonces effectivement
verizon de s'ouvrir jeu